five Grammys and the last one you got
that you just got was for art direction
that's right what's that all about well
I've been a recording artist for the
last several decades to kind of get my
foot in the door because art direction
is really my passion you want to get
into art direction the easiest way to
get in is like gonna be a recording
artist for 30 40 years yeah yeah let you
fly through where do you keep the
Grammys if you had if I had five Grammys
they would be prominently displayed and
some people don't have five Grammys and
I feel sorry for those people I am one
of them I have no I have no Grammys
shocking well - I usually have a fix to
my forehead with wood screws yeah you
wear them wherever you go I took them
out for this show cuz I thought that
might be distract the other three are
just helping to write the uneven
furniture very nice so you're using them
for practical purposes oh yeah yeah
alright and one of things does my Tia
just stare at them lovingly I hope you
caress them you know one of the things
that is a is sort of a I don't know I
guess it's a benefit of being in the
business so long and having such an
impact is that you have become the go-to
80s reference for television shows that
are based in that era this is a stranger
thing right stranger things I think we
have a photo here there's this scene
where nothing yeah
Dustin from stranger things is wearing a
retro Weird Al shirt and I is that good
friend I would think that must feel good
yeah that these very popular shows are
referencing you I'm hoping the next
season of stranger things will just be
wall-to-wall Weird Al just all the time
we actually offered that very shirt on
my last tour and it was like our biggest
seller and it's actually available on my
website Weird Al calm right now as we
speak
only given at twenty years or so it's a
whopper hey I did not okay this how dare
you sir I said I would think this would
he's gotta come down at some point